B Cell Activation can happen in two
different ways th dependent B Cell
Activation involves the T helper cell
there are MHC and TCR interaction as
well as there is cd40 and cd40 ligand
interaction these two signals lead to
the B Cell Activation
and in the second mode in t independent
B Cell Activation there could be cross
linking of the B cell receptors from by
the bacterial peptides may be flagellin
or maybe other components of the
bacteria
in both these cases the strong
activation happens in a th dependent
manner
once it is activated it would
proliferate an increase in number this
is called clonal expansion
activated B cell would eventually
differentiate into plasma cells which
would undergo class switching and lead
to production of antibodies watch the
full video to know more